all right we are taking calls for one of
the last times of 2019 the phone number
is of course six one seven eight three
zero
4750 let's go next to our caller from
the three one seven area code who's
calling today from three one seven three
one side I heard you click on it yeah
they are hi there um my question is um
I've heard you talk about from not
likely being impeach due to the
Republicans just smacking it down in the
Senate do you think he has a real shot
at being president despite going back on
all of his campaign promises and using
ice the way he is allowing children to
die in custody like how will that not
destroy him in in the upcoming election
like what are your thoughts because his
vote his supporters either don't care or
don't believe it or think that it's the
fault of Democrats or fill in the blanks
so yeah I so Trump will I don't believe
Trump will be convicted by the Senate on
impeachment I do unfortunately think
that unless we really get turnout up and
really do what is gonna be very hard
work as a general rule it's hard to
knock off an incumbent president it's
particularly difficult when you have one
with a cult of personality around them
the cult of personality around george w
bush was nothing compared to the cult of
personality around Donald Trump so III
agree with you how would someone vote
for this I understand your frustration I
hear the frustration in your voice but
unfortunately I think that Trump is
likely to lose the popular vote but he
very well may win the electoral college
again and get reelected to another four
years and it'll be horrible oh my gosh
well that was the question the answer I
was hoping not to get but I I appreciate
that it seems like the situation and but
but listen it's not losing right I mean
that's the thing we've got it we it's us
it's we've half the country doesn't vote
if people go out and vote it's very easy
we don't even really have to convince
anyone to change their mind about Trump
we just have to make sure that the
people that normally don't vote and
might
otherwise vote go out and vote and then
we win it's just easier said than done
right right well I'll be I'll be looking
forward to it for sure all right thank
you so much for the call very much
appreciate hearing from you